today we're gonna move on to
uh another topic i've kept hinting at
all semester but it's finally here
which is to think more explicitly about
equity or fairness
so our discussions this semester have
been almost solely couched in the
language of efficiency
we talk about maximizing social welfare
we talk about the total size of the
triangle and the squares
but we don't actually talk about who
gets what we've very much stayed away
from
equity concerns and focus just on
efficiency concerns
the problem is that doesn't lead us very
far in life
because you can have many outcomes that
are equally efficient
but have different equity consequences
the best example of course is perfect
competition
versus a perfectly price discriminating
monopolist remember
under perfect competition you maximize
welfare
but a perfectly price discriminating
monopolist also maximizes welfare
the difference is in the latter case the
monopolist gets all the surplus
when the former case is shared between
producers and consumers
so it's sort of weird to say we're
indifferent between those two outcomes
between one where apple gets all our
money and when we're apple gets some of
our money and we get some of our money
seems like kind of a strange uh strange
to say we're different between those
outcomes
so now that's sort of the
in some sense that's the easy case so
we're talking about equity efficiency
in some sense the easy case is the case
where
there's two equally efficient outcomes
and they have different equity
consequences that's the rare case
the more common case is what we call the
equity efficiency trade-off
which is that by making distributions
more equal
we are going to induce inefficiencies
that the act of making distribution more
equal
is going to introduce inefficiencies in
the system and that's where things get
really interesting
okay so in other words so the best way
to think about this
i find most helpful is due to a famous
economist named arthur oaken
and his thought example of the leaky
bucket
oaken's thought example was the
following imagine that the way the
government distributed money from the
rich the poor was literally they went to
the rich
had the rich put money in a bucket and
they carried it and dumped out in front
of the poor
imagine that's the way distribution
happened well in that world
if i told you that every dollar a rich
person put in the bucket
got carried along and got handed to a
poor person so bill gates dollar became
a homeless guy's dollar
probably most of us would think that was
okay
i think the vast majority of americans
say yeah probably the homeless guy can
use a dollar more than bill gates could
okay but now imagine that there was a
leak in the bucket
imagine bill gates put 100 pennies in
but along the way to the poor person it
leaked out and so we dumped it from the
poor person that was less than 100.
now then the question is how much
leakage well if the leakage was
one penny out of 100 you probably
wouldn't change your mind
would it change your mind if it was 20
pennies i have a hundred
50 pennies out of a hundred what if it
was a hundred pennies out of a hundred
what if taking a dollar from bill gates
by time we got to the poor person it was
all gone
at what point would you say you know
what i don't think that's a good idea
anymore
and really that's a great way of
thinking about the equity efficiency
trade-off
how much efficiency are you willing to
give up to restream from rich to poor
and the efficiency you give up is
represented by the leakage in the bucket
okay now what we're going to do
in this lecture and next monday's
lecture is we're going to discuss
this equity efficiency trade-off in four
steps
okay the first step is going to be
talking about
valuation that is taking the difficult
step we've avoided taking so far and
asking
how does society feel about some people
versus other people so far we just
thought of one generic person
and they're represented by total surplus
but in fact we have a distribution of
people
and how do economists think about taking
money away from person a and giving to
person b
that's a new topic for us the second
thing we're going to talk about
is what do we know about
um the facts on inequality
what do we know about what's actually
happened to the distribution of
resources
uh in the u.s at a point in time and
over time
the third thing is we're going to talk
about the sources of leakage
that is why does the bucket leak in
practice why do we typically think there
is an equity efficiency tradeoff why
can't we just take the dolphin rich guy
and give it to the poor guy what caused
the leakage
and then finally we're going to talk
about
some examples of transfer mechanisms
we're going to talk about what society
does in practice
to transfer from rich to poor and how it
works and what
what the ultimate leakage looks like
okay
so that's going to be our goal in the
next two lectures
it's going to think about this equity
efficiency trade-off so to start that
goal
we have to start with this first issue
of choosing the social optimum
that is how do we evaluate
transfers from one party to another
party
okay and so to rank
outcomes what we're going to do is use
the same thing we always do
when we want to think about trade-offs
which is we're going to do a constrained
maximization exercise
what i want to think about your
trade-off between cookies and pizza
i did a constrained optimization utility
function subject to your budget
constraint
well i now want to think about your
trade-off between me and patricia
now instead we're gonna need a different
utility function in fact we're gonna use
what we call a
social welfare function a social welfare
function is basically society's utility
function
how does society value different
individuals
okay so loosely so loofly speaking
social water function is some
function of utility of person one comma
utility of person two comma dot dot dot
com utility of person 350 million if
it's the u.s
okay so it's some aggregation function
just like we mathematically aggregate
your taste for pizza and cookies now
we're going to mathematically aggregate
all society's utility to get a social
welfare function
so for example consider figure 21-1
okay let's think of society as only two
people homer and ned
let's imagine that's all of society
because once again it's always these two
by two examples are easy
okay what we've drawn here are what's
called iso welfare curves
what these are are basically society's
indifference curves
just like if these x if these x and y
axis said pizza and cookies
i would draw on a difference curve
between pizza and cookies now i'm
drawing
society's indifference curve between
homer and ned
so in other words what this says is that
society is indifferent
between homer having u1 super h and ned
having u1 super n
versus the meet homer having you two
super h and then having you two super ed
those are those are combinations of
resources across which society's
indifferent
and much like any other indifference
curve further out is better
we'd all prefer both homer and ned to
have more more is better
okay so that's easier the further out
the iso welfare curve goes the happier
you are
and along the iso well for curve are
allocations of resources across
individuals among which were indifferent
okay now the question is that's all well
and easy to graph as a theoretical
proposition
but in practice what does the social
welfare function look like
utility functions i just wrote down with
utility function
and you took it as sort of you know i
wrote down square root we worked with
that
but there were some properties we wrote
down that sort of gave us a sense what
utility functions look like
social welfare functions are much more
open because they don't come from
introspection about your preferences
they come from an introspection about
society's preferences which are much
harder
so what we do here is we talk about some
typical forms of social welfare
functions
that we use in economics the most common
form is what's called utilitarian
social welfare function utilitarian
social welfare function this is due to
the philosopher jeremy bentham
if you ever visit university college
london actually if you did until about
15 years ago you could see jared
benson's head
it was on display he was a famous
philosopher there but apparently the
students would take it out use it for
soccer
so they took it off display you can't
see it anymore but he's a famous
philosopher
and he gave with the idea of
utilitarianism
and basically utilitarianism is it
simply says the social welfare function
is simply
the linear aggregation of every
individual's utility
so social welfare function is simply u1
plus u2 plus u3
plus plus you 350 million
so the u.s social worker functions
literally we just measure everyone's
utility added up
and that's the social welfare function
and in subsets
it's a natural starting point right you
just say look it's just a linear
it's like having a linear utility
function it's a it's a linear utility
function
now let's be clear
what this says is that i don't care
anymore about anybody in society so i
don't care any more or less about bill
gates and the homeless guy
i treat them i i mean different between
them
okay but does this mean i wouldn't want
to transfer money
from bill gates to the homeless guy in
fact
i still would want to transfer and why
depending on the leakage
why because of the mission
yeah exactly i care about the utility of
the same but the next dollar is not
worth anything to bill gates it's worth
a lot to the homeless guy
so a utilitarian social wear function
which is a natural starting point i
don't think if it's particularly liberal
okay it's a natural starting point
you're just adding them up ends up with
a very
in substance redistributive conclusion
which is that you want to distribute
from rich to poor
indeed what the optimum with utilitarian
social welfare function
is that you want to redistribute until
marginal utilities are equal
so this calls this social order function
calls for fairly radical redistribution
this says you want to redistribute until
utilities are equal
marginal tails are equal i'm sorry yeah
it sounds like a population
this is like making a convict well once
again let's you're right i mean you just
add people and subtract people it
wouldn't be a problem
uh but but for now let's just assume the
population has just got one given
society
okay so if two people it's just ned and
homer just to add them up all it says
is as net has more resources than home
we're going to redistribute
indeed with this function if we make the
assumption
that total social welfare is total
social resources are fixed
that a society is a fixed budget
constraint that can't change
okay then what does this function imply
would be the optimal distribution of
income
so ignoring the fact that people might
work less or more hard ignore that
imagine it's just a total amount of
money society has
if that's you that's your social welfare
function what's the optimal distribution
of income
yes everyone yes good point fixed
resources and identical utility
functions
great point yeah exactly great
great catch if there's a fixed bundle of
income and everyone has identical
utility functions
then we simply would want everyone have
the same amount of money why
because giving someone a dollar would
make them less happy
than taking away from someone else would
make them sad it's all about diminishing
margin utility just like we talked about
last time
so now that might not be true for
example you guys said you know scrooge
mcduckis
nice cruise mcduck raise your hand if
you don't scrooge mcduck
okay not bad excuse me duck is his comic
character when i was a kid he used to
like to dive and swim in his money
now he clearly had a higher margin
utility the next dollar than i do
okay so if scrooge mcduck really likes
money we might want to let scrooge
mcduck have some extra money
but if utility functions are identical
and social resources are fixed this is
one equal distribution of income
that's really radical okay that's beyond
what any country in the world does
a perfectly good distribution of income
but it comes naturally out of this
fairly plain vanilla
social welfare function quite a striking
finding right
now but in fact if we think of this as
sort of our starting point
bentham was actually conservative this
is typically viewed as sort of a
conservative starting point even though
that's a very
liberal conclusion the more liberal
extreme
is what we call a rosy in social welfare
function
due to the philosopher uh james i think
rawls who was at harvard
john rawls i'm sorry he said
the goal of society is to maximize the
well-being
of its worst off member so rawlsy and
social welfare function
is the minimum of u1
comma u2 comma dot dot dot in other
words
all you care about is the worst off
person society
okay so rawlsy and social welfare
function would say oh care about the
worst off person in society
okay now let's take this crazy let's
think about where rawls came
came at this from rawls came at this
from
the concept that he called the veil of
ignorance which he said look
before you were born you know nothing
about what you're going to be you could
be born to rich or poor
healthy sick you have no idea you're
just a little embryo
okay from that perspective he said what
you would want is to make sure
that you're going to be okay and so from
that perspective society should want to
minimize the well-being of the worst-off
member
that was his rationalization but this
has really radical implications
not only does this say we want an equal
distribution of income
this says we would destroy any amount of
money of the rich
to give some money to the poor so
imagine what this says if i could take
if everyone's distribution of income is
equal in this class let's say our
society
okay except patricia has forty thousand
dollars more than more than everyone
else
then what that would say is we would
happily take forty thousand dollars away
from patricia to give one dollar to me
okay because i'm like everyone else the
worst off member let's say i'm one
dollar less than the rest of you
make it easy so you all have the same
amount of money i have one dollar less
she has forty thousand more
rawlsy would say would happily take away
her forty thousand give me a dollar
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense
okay but it's one sort of extreme
and it's basically this notion of kind
of it's in some sense rawlsy they have
an extremely risk-averse
embryo gives you the rawlsian the idea
that i don't know what my income is
going to be but i want to make sure i'm
not poor then i would want sort of a
rawlsy and social welfare function
okay so that's that's sort of the
liberal um
uh extreme okay now
there's two other views which are harder
to write down mathematically
at least in the context of 1401 but are
important
there is let's take the most
conservative extreme so if rawlsy is the
most liberal extreme
the most conservative extreme would be
uh the nozick
nozickian argument it's not really
social welfare function his argument
is that we should never redistribute
income we should only redistribute
opportunities
in other words once everyone has equal
opportunities then we should just roll
the dice and let things lay on what they
may
so here's an example let's say all of us
are born with the same opportunities in
life
and we end up where we are today and
let's say that you guys are willing
to pay me ten dollars every lecture to
hear me lecture
well if that's true with the end
semester i have a lot more money than
you
nozik would say well why should i be
taxed and given to you that makes no
sense
you voluntarily paid me why should
lebron james are voluntarily paying to
see him play
why should he then be taxed on the money
we voluntarily gave him
so knows excuses as long as we all start
with an equality of opportunity
let the dice roll if someone has more
talents and skills
and people want to pay them then let
them keep it
so basically rawls's idea nozick's idea
is to essentially equalize opportunity
and let the dice
land where they may yeah
is this just like opportunity that can
be regulated or like is it like because
i
was thinking that problems with the
brock james by being like
tall and fit like doesn't have equal
opportunity right
so there's two problems with the nozeki
view one is what is opportunity
what does equal opportunity mean
and the answer is it's not clear there's
genetic equal opportunity there's
the fact that if i'm born in poverty i
go to lower quality schools so i don't
really have an equal opportunity
i went to ritzy you know public high
school in new jersey because my parents
were well off
like someone who went to high school in
some poor town new jersey didn't have
the same opportunities i did
so the first problem with this argument
is that in subsets
it's impossible to equalize opportunity
it sort of starts with a false premise
okay the second problem with this
argument is it
ignores luck
it ignores luck okay which is that in
fact
if you look at why some people are rich
and some people are poor even with equal
opportunities
a lot of it's not skill or talent it's
luck
they were in the right place at the
right time they the right parents who
gave them the right
you know inheritance uh they met the
right person in business school and went
on to and that person brought them into
their company
it's luck indeed if you try to explain
differences in income
by any measure of skill we have you can
never explain even half of the
difference in income across people
a lot of it appears to be luck well in
that case we would then
not want to let lucky people be richer
than unlucky people
that doesn't really seem to make sense
well i want skilled people richer than
unskilled people but
it doesn't seem it seems like we might
redistribute against from the lucky to
the unlucky so that's the other problem
with the
with the nozikian notion and then
finally the fourth
approach the fourth approach
is um a totally alternative view
which we call commodity egalitarianism
commodity egalitarianism
this view is simply saying look who
cares
how much money i have relevant to you
all that matters that you can live a
decent life
this says what matters is not relative
income
but absolute resources what matters is
making sure
everyone in society has food and shelter
and i would argue health care etc
a set of big things everyone should have
and then above that
who cares so in some sense commodities
egalitarians is kind of a mix of rawls
and nozick
it cares about the minimum saying we've
got to break sure everyone has a decent
state of living
but above that let's roll the dice as
long as we have
as long as we're providing a decent
state of living for everyone that if
someone can make a lot of money let's
let them
okay so this is a very interesting view
and it basically talks about the view of
kind of should we
give people money or stuff and so the
commodity egalitarianism view says
look it's let's worry less about money
more about stuff let's make sure
everybody has enough
stuff to lead a decent life and then
we'll roll the dice from there
so let me start if i was not clear
enough at all
none of these are right okay these are
all alternative views
it is harder to write down to make an
assumption about social welfare function
is about a utility function
we have less primitives to draw on but
the point is these are all
different ways of thinking about the
trade-off we can't avoid thinking about
the trade-off
that's why once again we're the dismal
science okay because nothing's free
we can't always think about the
trade-off we have to think about
redistribution
and these give us different frameworks
for thinking about that okay
questions about that yeah what
for like um yeah what happens if like
there are individuals that
just don't they they always make like
they'll always make the wrong decision
like they'll spend all their money like
irresponsibly and therefore like they
can't have a good example
well i mean that that's a very
interesting question so i think
nozick i mean i don't know i don't know
how hard-hearted a guy knows it is
but if you took to noziki and view to
the extreme as long as that person had
an equal opportunity then they should
just die
i mean you know they had an equal
opportunity if they made a series of bad
decisions
why should we care now that's obviously
an extreme view but i think that would
be the
the the view there whereas commodity
terrorism would say look
let's at least make sure that despite
their bad decisions
they don't starve but we still don't
want to make them rich if they're making
bad decisions
so let's just set a minimum and get into
that and then let things go from there
okay yeah
that's a great segue to what i'm going
to talk about next which is let's
actually talk about
territories into practice and measuring
inequality
and i'm going to come back to your basic
income point in a couple minutes so
let's talk about actually measuring
inequality
okay and the reason we don't talk about
this because it highlights how important
this issue is
so let's go to some facts these are from
my uh textbook from 1441.
okay so go to figure 21-2
ignore the last row for a second focus
on the first five rows
what the first five rows show is the
percent of
income received by each quintile or each
fifth
of the income distribution in other
words each row
is twenty percent of people so the first
row is the poorest twenty percent of
people
the next row is the second poorest
twenty percent of people and so on
the numbers in each cell are the share
of income held by that quintile
in other words if the distribution of
income was totally equal everyone's
numbers would be 20.
distribution was totally equal every
quintile would have 20. but in fact
that's never been true in any society
ever in history
the richest always have more than the
poorest we have no perfect distribution
of income
and you see that if you look at in 1967
when these data's first
are reliably collected you see that the
highest 20 percent of individuals
had about 10 times as much as the lowest
20
okay that there was a lot of inequality
okay now if you roll forward till about
1980
that gap was shrinking so you saw that
the highest 20
share was about fixed but the lowest 20
percent was rising
but then if you look since 1980 that gap
has wind enormous wide and enormously
the point now where the 2013 is the
latest here but the facts haven't really
changed
the richest 20 of americans earned more
than half the income in america
and the poorest 20 earn only about 3 of
the income in america
so inequalities widen massively in the
u.s
okay how does that put us in
international terms
uh oh okay and i'm sorry and then the
last row is the share of the top five
percent this is particularly striking
in fact go to the next page this is a
graph the share of the top one percent
of income holders in america
this is the share of income held by the
one percent richest americans
you can see that in the early 20th
century that was pretty high almost 20
percent
it then fell down about 10 percent by
the early 1970s
it's now up and by the latest state up
to about 25
it's higher than it was at the beginning
of 20th century so the one percent of
richest americans have about
25 of the income earned in society so
it's extremely unequal income
distribution
i'm once again not saying bad or good
i'm making a positive statement unequal
is irrefutable bad or good we'll get to
but they're refutable very unequal
income distribution it's also
irrefutable we have a
much more unequal distribution of income
than the rest of the world
so in figure 21-4 we compare the facts
for the u.s the rest the oecd which is a
said developed economies yeah
that's a great point it's all about this
is all before tax before tax but if
anything
if you add taxes it makes us look even
worse relative to other countries
because our attacks are less progressive
than other countries okay this before
tax then before transfers
so if you look at other so this list is
a lot of numbers
look at the bottom line the bottom line
is the average across
all non-us countries of the share of
income
held by each part of the income
distribution and uh the next bottom line
the bottom line is the u.s so we say the
bottom ten percent
of legal distribution on average across
these countries has three percent of
income
indeed nowhere except for mexico
is the number lower than the 1.6 percent
in the u.s
likewise if you look at the top 10
percent of income earners
on average across these countries uh
they earn 25
of the income in the u.s it's 30 and
indeed
nowhere is the number higher than in uh
except in mexico and turkey
so we are the most unequal country
except for mexico
in of on this list once again not saying
good or bad
just saying the facts okay we're gonna
come to we're come to how we think about
good or bad
okay so those are the facts about
inequality but as the question here
pointed out
it's not clear we care about inequality
indeed in a standard economic framework
i don't care about inequality my utility
is a function of my consumption not your
consumption
so standard economic framework i don't
care about inequality i just care about
what i have
and that speaks more to the commodity
commodity egalitarianism view
which is how are we doing in making sure
people have enough to live and to do
that
um we say we move from so when we talk
about inequality
inequality is a measure of relative
distribution we want to move to
something which the measure of absolute
absolute dis income and that's what we
call the poverty line
the poverty line in the u.s a measure of
absolute deprivation
what share of americans are earning less
than some minimum standard they need to
live
now you can immediately see the problem
with inequality
it's unit free right i simply compare
dollars to dollars
once i start going here i have to make a
judgment which is what is deprivation
what do you need to live so in substance
this makes more sense
absolutely makes more sense in some
sense it makes more sense think about do
people have enough to live on
but it is more difficult because you
have to draw a judgment
about what it is so the judgment we've
drawn is what's called the poverty line
the poverty line was invented by a civil
servant in the 1960s
molly orshinsky she said well what does
it take to live in america
said well the typical person spends
about a third of their budget on food
in the 1960s so let's cost out
the cost of a nutritionally adequate
bundle of food
multiply it by three and call that the
poverty line
she did that and that's still the
poverty line all we've done is taken
that and updated it by inflation
remember we talked about the cpi the
inflation rate
all we've done is taken molly or chances
poverty line updated by inflation ever
since
and what do we get well if you look at
table 21.5 this shows you the poverty
line
in the u.s today it varies by family
size because you need more resources
with a bigger family
but not one to one because of economies
of scale in the household
you don't need twice as much money to
have a household with two people because
you only
you still only need one living unit you
can share cookware
you only you can only have to heat
heating for two people so much more
except than heating for one person etc
so there's economies of scale within the
household so poverty line does not go up
does not double with every person you
does not does not double you go from one
to two it's less than doubles
and you could see this scale essentially
we
say that uh this is 2015 it's so it's
higher now
but baseless says that one person with
income below 11
170 is living in poverty and a family of
four
it's about 24 250. it's about 24
20 so basically say a family below 25
000
a family for below 25 000 is living in
poverty okay
now is that um is that
the right number well yeah
there's a number of reasons it might not
be the right number first of all it does
not differ based on what country lives
so
if you are you guys don't know because
you're sheltered but if you tried to
right now try to take twenty five
thousand dollars go live in boston
there's no way
i mean there's no it's just like
impossible whereas in rural mississippi
you can probably do okay in twenty five
thousand dollars
so but it doesn't vary by area uh it
doesn't vary it also
um uh the poverty line calculation is
all messed up now because when she did
it food was a third of people's budgets
it's now more like 20 of people's
budgets it's fallen enormously
and the elements the other elements that
poor people have to pay notably housing
and medical care
have gone up much faster and the poverty
line hasn't accounted for that
um so in fact there's lots of reasons
that this line is problematic
nonetheless it's very hard to change it
indeed i was in the u.s government
for 14 months and i only went to one
super duper secret meeting okay i went
to a lot of meetings with the president
stuff like that
but one time my secretary said there's a
meeting and i can't tell you what it's
about i can't even tell you where it is
when the time comes they will come get
you and bring you there
i was like jesus it's nuclear war like
what the hell
so they brought me to this room we're
all in this room i'm like what's going
on they're like we need to discuss
revising the poverty line
i'm like what well why is it super
secret
because the us today distributes more
than a trillion dollars a year
based on the poverty line so any changes
you make
is going to create winners and losers
and the losers are going to be really
mad okay
and as a result it's been incredibly
hard to change the poverty line
because for example let's say we change
it to recognize the fact that it should
be higher in new york than mississippi
well that means new yorkers would win
and mississippians would lose
bad news politically new yorkers would
be happy mississippi should be sad but
because the mission march utility
and the laws of politics the guys who
are sad make more noise than the guys
who are happy
so it's very very hard to change this
despite it's despite its problematic
features
nonetheless it's still a useful
benchmark it is useful that it's fixed
over time because it allows us to
essentially see how things have evolved
over time and we can see that
in figure 21 6.
this shows the poverty rate over time
and it shows it for
everybody that's the red it shows it for
the elderly that's the blue
for kids that's the green and for
non-elderly adults that's the yellow
so what do we see here we see a couple
things first of all for every group
poverty fell enormously during the 1960s
that's the so-called war on poverty we
choose a number of social programs
that lowered poverty enormously during
the 1960s
okay for the elderly it kept going down
and the elderly went from the most
impoverished group in society
to the least for kids
it bounced back up and now kid poverty
rates
are nearly as high as they were back in
the night early 1960s
for the rest of folks it sort of went
down then flattened yeah
how do you determine how much wealth a
kid has uh it's based on their family's
income
this is not wealth it's income it's
based in their so basically when ask
does a kid live in poverty it's like do
they live in a household that's below
the poverty line
okay so the bottom line is so think
about so let's say this is families with
kids is another way to think about this
the bottom line is essentially poverty
hasn't done a whole lot we haven't done
a whole lot on poverty in the last
50 years okay we sort of lowered a lot
in the 60s and then it's been it's been
bounced up and down but it's been pretty
flat
okay is it is the result there
now so the bottom line is i my now my
take now i'm going to draw a judgment
my take is along all these dimensions we
don't look so hot
okay we're the most unequal nation in
the world and we have
you know uh still if you look at all
people
we have 15 of our people living below
some standard of absolute deprivation
literally saying we are accepting if 15
of people in america cannot afford to
live
okay we are sort of accepting that
including uh you know more than 20
percent of kids
okay so i don't think we're doing that
well but in some sense this is even the
most yeah
go ahead 18
64 people yeah are those like single
people because i imagine like
kids would fall within the thing i mean
that's like the average of all 18 to 64
including those that have kids and don't
so look at childless 864 that would come
down more
says the average now this is a striking
set of facts but not to my mind the most
striking
probably the most striking fact that
probably probably the fact i've seen
the most influence on me in the last 10
years is shown in figure 21 7.
this is a figure put together in the
wake of the freddie gray riots in
baltimore
you may have heard about those that's
when a uh prisoner was beat to death in
the back of a police van
and he was tap from the area of sandtown
okay sandtown winchester which is a
super bad area think the wire if you see
the wire like super bad area of
baltimore
okay about three miles away is an area
called roland park
which is a very rich area the average
life expectancy in roland park
is 84 years that's above the u.s average
that's pretty good
the average life expectancy three miles
away
is 67 years which is below north korea
and what it was around world war ii in
the u.s
three miles and we get a 17-year
difference
in the average life expectancy what's
going on
well what you'd expect people are way
poorer
in sound town the average income is 107
000
i'm sorry in roland park it's 107 000.
in sandtown it's 24 000. the average
income is below the poverty line
in roland park 2.5 percent of kids live
in poverty and standtown is 55 percent
of kids
okay so basically you have incredibly
incredible inequality and short
distances to me this is striking
because it really brings home how much
brings home the inequality by putting it
in such sort of close
geographic terms so we have a lot of
inequality
there's no there's no question and this
certainly motivates
i think it's hard to look at facts like
this regardless of your political stripe
and not worry not at least worry
and consider the fact that there may be
some role for government redistribution
okay but that that's not the end of the
discussion
okay this in some sense think of this as
sort of
this part of the lecture sort of the
benefits of government redistribution
the benefits of government distribution
we have incredible inequality incredible
poverty
uh all around the country now we have to
come but of course in economics nothing
free
now we have to come to the cost of
redistribution
the benefits are clear what about the
costs
and so now we have to talk about uh
the efficiency costs or the leakage
efficiency costs
costs of redistribution
or in other words how big is the leakage
so going back to oaken i hope that these
figures inspire you to think we ought to
be putting some money in buckets and
giving it to poor people
but now the question is should we what
if it all leaks out how leaky is the
bucket
and that's what you talk about now and
basically
leakages in the bucket come from three
sources
the first and least important source is
administrative costs
literally you got to pay someone to
carry the bucket okay so if you put a
dollar in and carry the bucket
he's going to take some money out for
the right of carrying the bucket that's
small
but non-trivial maybe low single digits
the second source of leakage is
the efficiency costs of taxation
if you tax people and take their money
away
they may work less hard think about the
extreme case where i'm going to say
i'm going to go back to the utilitarian
world i'm going to tell everyone we're
going to equalize income
that means that everyone no matter what
they make example the same amount of
money
why would you work i mean you guys would
because your tools but like
why would what why would like why would
like regular people work
okay they wouldn't because no matter
what you do you end up with the same
income
it's 100 tax so why would you work
that's extreme but the point is
the extreme exam makes a point that when
you tax people there's potential
efficiency costs in terms of them
earning less income the third issue
is the efficiency costs
of transfers
which is when you give people money
and you give that money when you get
money they may also work less so not
only might i work less when you tax me
i might work less if you give me money
why should go to work if you're sending
me a check
so not only would an equal distribution
of income leave me to work less than
being taxed leave me with less because
i'm getting money so why should i bother
working
as long as leisure's a normal good
remember i don't want to work
so if you're just sending me money why
would i go to work
okay so to see this we can sort of
summarize this
with with one example so let's go to
figure 21.8
and i want to sort of walk through some
fairly complicated examples walk through
this is a simple illustration of a tax
and transfer scheme of the type we have
in america we start
in this example with an individual
earning twenty dollars an hour
so the slope of this line is negative
twenty dollars an hour this person can
work
two that can and on remember we don't
model work we model leisure i almost
made the mistake
remember we don't model the bad we model
the good we don't model
labor without our leisure let's say that
the max leisure can take is two thousand
two thousand hours okay so you can
either take two thousand dollars of
leisure and earn and consume nothing
or you could take no leisure consume 40
000 and let's say consumption's income
no savings in this model
okay so you're in 20 an hour you consume
your whole income
and you can take up to 2 000 hours of
leisure
okay so your budget constraint is the
dark line running from 40 000 on the
y-axis 2000 on the x-axis
okay now let's say that we're going to
put
in into this budget constraint we're
going to add two things the first is a
transfer program to the poor
we're worried about poverty so we're
gonna have a new program
that says that every american
gets at least ten thousand dollars
everyone's ten thousand dollars
but as their income goes up we're going
to take that away
so we're going to say since we have a
transfer program
the transfer program is going to be of
the form the transfer you get
is the max of zero comma ten thousand
minus your income that's our transfer
program
so if your income zero you get ten
thousand
if you're gonna said thousand you get
zero we're just making sure everybody
gets ten thousand dollars
we don't care about people having more
than that so we're gonna take it away
we're gonna say look want to make sure
you have ten thousand dollars
but above that we don't care about you
okay so if you're someone earning a
hundred thousand dollars this program's
irrelevant
okay if you're someone earning five
thousand dollars we'll give you another
five thousand dollars
to get you up to ten okay so that's
based our transfer program
this is typically the way welfare
programs work around the world
okay essentially they give you money but
then they take it away as you get richer
to make sure the money's targeted to the
poorest people okay
so that's our transfer program that's
the first thing it's going to do
the second thing it's good the second
thing we're going to transfer but we've
got to pay for this
so payments we have to have a tax now
let's say we only want to tax the rich
you want to tax the poor and give money
to the poor
so let's say our tax program is of the
following form
anyone making more than 20 000 per year
pays a 20 tax rate on the income above
20 000. so no one's taxed on their first
20 000
but in every dollar above 20 000 you pay
20 cents to the government
it's what's called a marginal tax
okay it's a marginal you have a marginal
tax rate
of 20 percent what does marginal mean it
means you only pay on the next dollar
so it's a marginal tax march 20 percent
above
20k okay so once you earn 20k
up 20k you pay nothing once you earn 20k
on
every dollar above 20k you face a
marginal tax rate of 20
you pay 20 cents of every dollar of the
government
okay so that is our tax program not
looking at the diagram do people
understand
how these programs work for getting the
diagram yeah manny
in other countries uh like is there any
like data that's showing like how this
affects the number like the number of
hours people work that's exactly where
we're getting to
um that's our concern right is that
that's my point here is that this might
lower how many hours people work
okay and let's talk about why but the
question about the logistics of these
programs first
okay well let's talk about how it effect
hours worked let's go to
the diagram okay let's go to the diagram
let's consider several different people
start with person
a person a earned
let's they earn some that before this
program was in place
they would have chosen to be a high
leisure low consumption person
when this program is in place we tell
them look person a
you can get more of both
more leisure and more consumption all
you have to do is quit
stop working you move from point a to
point d
you get more leisure and more
consumption so that naturally happens
so everyone earning less than 10 000
immediately quits
once again assuming less is a normal
good immediately quits because
because look once you're below ten
thousands 100 tax rate
why work so anyone who would have earned
less than 10 000 doesn't work
because you're just going to give back
to the government anyway why do you care
that's person a what about person b
person b earns more than ten thousand
but note their indifference curve
crosses below the new budget straight
let me step back the new budget strain
is the red segments plus the black
segment in the middle
new budget constraint runs from 32 000
on the y-axis it intersects the black
line the old budget's turning to 20
thousand dollars
it's the old budget straight from twenty
thousand dollars down to ten thousand
dollars and it becomes the new red
segment
i should mention that so the new budget
strain is the two red segments
and the black segment in between that's
the new budget constraint
so let's look at person b what happens
to person b and y
what does person be do and yeah why
because it's a hard difference right
crucially
since person b's at every serve crosses
the red line
we know they must be better off at point
d than at point b
because we know that since point d is
above that line that's that's a higher
indifference curve than the run at point
b
so not only do you cause every person
below ten thousand to quit you also
cause some people above ten thousand to
quit
why well they give up a little
consumption they get a ton of leisure
so let's say someone's doing eleven
twelve thousand like wait a second
all my work is only getting me a
thousand two thousand dollars over
quitting i might as well quit
so this welfare program caused a ton of
people to quit
all the people who are going to earn
very little quit and some people are
giving errands somewhat little quit
okay but that's not all let's look at
person c
person c used to work a certain amount
you know used to work
you know more than a thousand hours take
less than a thousand hours of leisure
now what happens well what happens
forget the diagram step back if i take
someone
and introduce a marginal tax rate what
happens to their labor supply
and why what happens to their leisure
and why
so i take you you're working let's say
you were you're taking
800 hours of leisure doesn't matter what
the exact number was
i then come and say you have a 20 tax
rate and every earnings about 20 000
how does that affect your your leisure
yeah you would increase it why
because then after about 10 000 um you
get like
i guess you can get less money but i
guess maybe less utility out of above
10k
since you're right you might increase it
but what else you do
yeah the wage effectively decreases so
the price of leisure decreases
so you take more likely right i think
that you increase leisure that's what he
said
okay increase leisure but what else yeah
you might increase it just to like cover
um taxes so you might work yeah what do
we what do we call the two effects
exactly we have substitution income
effects the substitution effect
would say your net wage is lower your
net weight just went from twenty dollars
an hour to sixteen dollars an hour
right so a lower net wage you work less
but the income effect says you work more
because you're now effectively poorer
when you're poorer you consume less of
everything including leisure
so when you tax my wage
i might work i might take less leisure
i.e work more
through the substitution effect i'm
sorry we taxed my wage i might take more
i might take more leisure i.e work less
the substitution effect
because the returns to work are lower
but i might take less leisure
you work more because i'm now poorer so
we don't know what's going to happen
but we typically assume substitution
effects dominate you can't go wrong in
this class
without making that assumption okay we
want you to remember the trade-off
but typically assume substitution of x
dominates so we typically think people
will work less
we think taxing people cause them to
work less but be clear it's not obvious
it will
but we typically think that's the result
and typically once again when you
average men and women as we discussed in
our labor supply lecture
overall you get an upward sloping labor
supply curve that is overall if you tax
people they'll work less
okay so what that does it lowers the
hours of work for person c
this is our leaks in the bucket we've
suddenly massively reduced the amount
potentially massively reduce the amount
people want to work
why do we care we care because of figure
219
what have we done we've gone from an
initial point
where people initially were supplying s
had initial supply curve of s1
and demand curve of d and therefore
we're supplying
l1 hours of le of labor at a wage w1
now they're they're producing less their
supply curve shift in
that's created a deadweight loss
there is less stuff being produced
because people are staying home rather
than working
and the key point is that's not a
problem okay staying home around the
zone's problem the problem is
they're staying home only because we've
reduced the price
of labor we've we've increased the price
we've reduced the price of leisure
i'm sorry we've we've reduced the return
to labor we've reduced the price of
leisure
as a result people are staying home
we've distorted their behavior
we've caused them to stay home and not
work because we're not working there's
less stuff for the rest of us
so there's a deadweight loss efficiency
falls
and that is the efficiency equity
trade-off this deadweight loss
is okan's leak that's the leak in
oaken's bucket
so now we have the trade-off on the one
hand we have an incredibly unequal
society
where a program like this could really
make people better off take money from
rich people who don't need it
give to poor people who do on the other
hand in doing so we're going to have
less stuff with society
we're going to shrink the size of the
pie in order to redistribute the slices
of the pie
is it worth it that's where the social
welfare function comes in
the social welfare function allows you
to evaluate
whether something like this is worth it
without a social function you can never
answer that question
you just can't because there's one hand
on the other hand what a social welfare
function does give you a mathematical
representation
allows you to answer that question so in
section on friday you work through an
example
of using a social welfare function to
evaluate a welfare transfer program like
this
okay and then we'll come back on monday
and talk more about taxation
you